Nimmt man „Breakfast“ wörtlich, dann kann
das Sonntagsfrühstück schon mal
als Schlacht mit Beil und Säge enden –
so geschehen in der Fotoserie „Break fast“,
was übersetzt so viel wie
„schnell zerbrechen“ bedeutet.
Es sind die Bilder der spanischen
Fotografin Tessa Dóniga,
die Nahrungsmittel und Alltagsgegenstände
zweckentfremdet in Szene setzt.
Ich würde meine Arbeit
mit drei Worten beschreiben:
eigenwillig,
detailliert
und absurd.
Heraus kommen surreale
Kompositionen wie ein Frühstücksei,
das mit scharfer Munition beschossen wird,
oder Pancakes, die anstatt in der Pfanne
mit dem Bügeleisen gebraten werden.
Als Kreativdirektorin fotografiert Tessa Dóniga
heute für eine Shopping-Mall in Madrid.
Vier Motive sollen auf Plakaten und in
Social-Media-Kanälen auf die Modegeschäfte
und die gastronomische Auswahl
aufmerksam machen.
Von klassischer Food-Fotografie hebt sich
Tessa Dóniga dabei ganz bewusst ab.
Okay, setz dich aufrechter hin und zeig,
dass du dich über den Schuh
und den Hotdog freust.
Was man bei mir in der Regel sieht,
ist Essen, das ein wenig deplatziert wirkt.
In einer Art, die man so noch nicht
gesehen hat – aus dem Kontext gehoben
und übertrieben inszeniert.
Hier haben wir ein Model, Mode und
eine Aktion, die spielerisch mit Essen umgeht.
Während ihres Kunststudiums entdeckt
Tessa Dóniga ihre Leidenschaft
für Fotografie und Film.
2015 gründet sie ihre eigene Agentur.
Sie dreht Werbespots und produziert
Fotoserien für Zeitschriften.
Ihr Markenzeichen: Pastellfarben und
reduzierte Bildkompositionen.
Ihr Spezialgebiet: Essen.
Mal exzentrisch, mal provokant inszeniert.
Die größte Herausforderung: Alles muss
frisch und perfekt aussehen.
Während das Model für das zweite Foto
gestylt wird,
ist Tessa Dóniga bereits unterwegs.
Das essbare Requisit fehlt noch.
Für ihr nächstes Motiv benötigt sie
ein perfekt gebratenes Spiegelei.
Mangels Kochzeile im Fotostudio besorgt sie
es kurzerhand im Café nebenan.
Spiegeleier sind empfindlich,
da sie schnell trocken werden.
Hier kann ich sie gleich mitnehmen.
Ich denke, ich kann maximal eine Stunde
mit ihnen arbeiten.
Wenn nicht, muss ich noch mal
hierherkommen.
Es geht eben nichts
über Improvisationstalent.
Die Eier habe ich. Hoffentlich fallen sie
mir unterwegs nicht runter.
Zurück im Studio setzt Tessa Dóniga
das Spiegelei umgehend in Szene.
Hauptaugenmerk liegt auf dem Eigelb, das
mit chirurgischer Präzision angepasst wird.
Das perfekte Ei für das Foto
ist eines, das glänzt,
eine schöne Farbe hat
und nicht angebrannt ist.
Natürlich bearbeiten wir
die Bilder später noch.
Aber es gilt: je mehr Glanz und Fülle,
desto besser.
Nur das Sandwich zu fotografieren,
das wäre zu einfach.
Stattdessen wird das Eigelb
zum Nagellack umfunktioniert.
Denn nur ungewöhnliche Geschichten
garantieren Aufmerksamkeit.
Ästhetisch schöne Bilder gibt es
wie Sand am Meer.
Das Internet ist voll davon.
Jeder hat heutzutage
ein Smartphone und macht Fotos.
Es ist viel komplizierter geworden,
eine witzige Geschichte zu erzählen
und sich abzuheben.
Egal ob Frühstück, Mittag-
oder Abendessen – auch die heutigen Fotos
von Tessa Dóniga machen Appetit auf mehr.